what was the moment for you when you
realized the mainstream media I just
they're not doing a good job of
Journalism anymore because I can tell
you what for a lot of people who are
sort of heterodoc Center where I see us
and right-leaning people too one of the
key moments was Jordan Peterson being
interviewed by Kathy Newman I don't know
if you remember that yeah of course and
a lot of people just went wait this
isn't this is fake this isn't a
conversation this isn't how people talk
if you had a a psychology professor in
your living room that you may disagree
with that's not how you would talk to
them and if you did talk to them like
that you'd think this person's demented
right was there a moment like that for
you coming from a left-wing perspective
where you were just like I saw that and
I was like okay there's no going back
for the mainstream anymore there's so
many I mean it happens every week
doesn't it I think for me one of the wow
moments was I think at the time Andrew
ma was the BBC political editor
and he wrote a novel which I find quite
strategy and you shouldn't really have
time to run over when you're running
hundreds of thousands of pounds paid by
the BBC but anyway maybe I'm being mean
and the um the launch party for that
novel can you guess where it was
number 10 Downing Street and so you
think your job is to scrutinize these
people they're doing you a favor to
launch your novel and I just thought
you're not serious like I don't you
shouldn't be hectoring them and being
angry with them but there should be a
slight free source like tension between
politicians and political journalists
there's just a bit wary of that guy be
careful don't you know don't be too
loose-lipped that's a that's healthy for
democracy and when I saw that story I
thought
the baby sees buggered and I think more
broadly the the relationship between
politicians and the media in this
country is bucket it is it is so
unhealthy and I think it's worse in the
US because in this country everything's
in London everything's in London whereas
in the US you've got your politicians in
Washington you've got your La people
your Texas people your New York people
it's here it's so bad
it isn't it it's a very profound Point
here it is bad
a moment for you where you realize that
left-wing media wasn't everything it
purported to be where you looked at
certain Outlets I mean maybe it's a
Godly maybe it's others where you
thought hang on a minute this isn't what
I associate with the left or left-wing
media well there's not that much
left-wing media in the UK so I mean I'd
start with the Daily Mirror it's been a
labor sporting paper for a very long
time
you know I don't know
I remember doing um BBC any questions
and I mentioned a story and then you
know these are this is Middle England
right I was somewhere in like Yeovil or
something you know lib Dem Tory floating
voters this is Middle England and I said
oh the storage from The Daily Mirror
they'll start laughing at me right
rightly so because for them it's just
it's a tabloid you know I don't think it
has necessary but a sort of political
take on things you know it's a spin on
you know it's like the Sun but the other
side I don't think it's quite as bad
yeah you know it's just that's the ball
POG the garden I think is a liberal
paper rather than a left paper but you
know we can park that for a moment what
I would say is the guardian
has really regressed so 10 years ago it
had The Bravery to do the Snowden stuff
it had the brave Ridge to the wikileak
stuff that would not happen now that
would really why not I think editorial
choices would just say I just don't
think it would happen I think well
definitely with Wikileaks Snowden I
don't know with um with Wikileaks and
the Glenn Greenwood staff I think you
know it's easy to say oh Alan rusbridge
is gone kathlein is the editor now they
wouldn't do that but I just feel like
there's not the same intellectual
curiosity they used to be at the
guardian in 15 years ago
um and I I I can't quite you know I
would buy the guardian 15 years ago I
wouldn't buy it I wouldn't pay for it
now you know I have a subscription for
theft I I read the ft and it's full of
facts and dates and I'll disagree with
all the columnists but it's useful high
value information I'm sorry to say the
guardian isn't that you know and do you
think part of the problem is identity
politics and writing through always the
prism of race and gender and that's not
to say that that doesn't have Merit
occasionally but that then means that
you just ignore the the sheer facts of
the situation what is happening on the
ground
the problem is I don't really read the
garden yeah so I don't know but you know
I I agree with your point here so for
instance there's something really
irritates me which is
um
your ex this person's why therefore this
person is the only person that can have
valid opinions on issues relating to why
people that can be with us to race
gender Etc so for instance I'm half
Iranian I might say
um I'm uh I think the process in Iran
um are bad I don't think they're bad I
might say they're bad I might say
something which is quite controversial
right
um at which point
um you know you might say somebody's not
arrangeable I disagree they seem quite
good you know it's about women's
Liberation civil liberties they seem
very positive I would say you can't have
a legitimate view on this because you
you're not Iranian somewhere in the
middle of all this are the facts and the
truth and values which don't really they
aren't contingent on on who you are your
identity and so on so on that point I I
agree with you is it a problem really
for the for the guardian it's a hard one
to say I mean I just don't read their
columns
that much I I think actually it's worse
than that in a way because this stuff is
percolated
a whole layer of the media and you can
find it in ad campaigns you can find it
in the guardian you might even find it
in in sort of sensor sensor right
newspapers sometimes yeah um for sure so
I think it's I think it's a bit bigger
than that actually yeah well our whole
society is infested with this idea
actually uh that we should look at
everything through the through the prism
of well you can't speak about this
because you're not that thing I agree I
was curious you mentioned there's no not
much left-wing media in the UK would you
do are you one of the people on the left
who feels that the BBC is Right leaning
C is liberal right so what do I mean by
that it's it's socially liberal and has
a social liberal agenda absolutely it
was absolutely opposed to brexit I say
that somebody voted remain it was
opposed to brexit
um and it's also economically liberal so
I think it's very
um
um what's the word circumspect about
radical economic ideas particularly from
the left but actually I think any kind
of radical electronic ideas anybody
who's saying there's a problem
let's try this solution an actual
solution oriented sort of mode of
thinking just doesn't sit well with them
um so I think lots of people from the
left dislike the BBC because they see
the fact it's economically liberal then
lots of people from the right see the
BBC and they say well it's socially
liberal and so I I can see both points
of view but it is and because we don't
have a successful Liberal Party in this
country anymore which we did until the
early 20th century it is very much a
continuation of that sort of patrician
liberalism which was the liberal party
you know um which broadly speaking after
it collapsed kind of becomes a faction
within both labor and the Tories so I
the the BBC has kind of progressive
moments and I'm sure it has it has like
journalists who are on the left for sure
but I would say it's a liberal a liberal
news organization so explain that to us
because those words liberal and left get
used very differently uh by different
people and they also get used very
differently in the United States versus
the UK like what do you mean what's the
difference how how are these things
different so a really a really great way
of explaining this I think is the fact
that BBC I think it's changed now but
they didn't have an industrial relations
correspondent they didn't have a labor
correspondent so they'd or or editor
rather than had a correspondent didn't
have a labor editor which they would
have had all the way through related to
the 1980s which is somebody whose job is
to say
these workers are getting screwed here a
thousand people have just been laid off
here a lot of the piano story for
instance right
um these people have gone on strike
they've got a big pay rise uh these
women are campaigning for better
maternity leave conditions at work etc
the BBC doesn't focus on that stuff now
somebody who's on the left I care about
that stuff right I care deeply about
that stuff instead the BBC will focus on
like
as a liberal organization
representation
um uh more women in boardrooms right I'm
not saying more winning boardrooms is
bad although it is I'm not saying it's
bad yeah but that affects a tiny Slither
of society yeah meanwhile you're not
talking about women organizing in their
workplaces for better maternity care
policies for instance yeah well so that
makes perfect sense and I remember
during the hole in gozie Fulani Affair
it was covered like it was a terrorist
attack when you sort of think there's
probably much bigger core issues
affecting way more people